chase anderson
signed this past offseason by the
phillies making his philly's debut
11 home runs last year in 33 and and two
thirds nimmo
one for three in last night's ball game
swing at a miss he got it back-to-back
change-ups and nimo goes down on strikes
oh it fool him badly back to back and
now marcus strowman renews his
relationship with the new york mets then
last year decided to up down accepted
the qualifying offer over the winter and
here he is on a one-year contract taking
a very deep breath and so marcus
strowman has walked the lead off man and
it'll bring up the third baseman
right hand hitting alec bone swinging a
bouncing ball to second to his left
mcneal has it to second one door to
first two a double play
four six three
marcus strowman ground ball generator
gets the four six three two out oh one
away and it brings up jd davis and it
got him on the hand and uh
he's upset
it was a four-seam fastball at 90 miles
an hour that ball just ran in on him and
kind of late to move well that sounded
painful yeah dave is going to be taken
out here he is walking back to the
dugout with brian chicklow
so now two men away and roman quinn
coming up oh
gets quinn in the foot and that'll load
up the bases
i don't think that is what strongman
wanted to do there guy over five with
four strikeouts you won get that eighth
hitter get the pitcher leading off the
next inning so chase anderson will bat
with the bases full anderson is a
lifetime 0.95 hitter and on the ground
to the right side moving to his left
mcneil he's got it throws the first in
time side retired the mets have their
lead off man on here in the fourth
here's dominic smith dom lifts one out
to left hit pretty well back goes joyce
near the wall it's out of here
dom smith with the men's first home run
of the season an opposite field two run
shot dominic smith with a dumbbell it's
the first mitch home run of 20-21 and it
gives the match a two-nothing lead and
that's why you'd like to see his bat in
there just about every day
let me admit that that's why he has to
have his bat in there every day
gregorius with an infield single earlier
the ball's in one strike to dede
gregorius after strowman picked up his
second strikeout out to center field
that's well hit going back on it as
nimbo back toward the wall it is gone
into the bushes
dede gregorius his first home run of the
year
and the phillies are on the board it's a
two-one game
a little sacred down in the zone and
dede goes down to get it with his legs
and
butches
literally push it joyce done for the day
so vince velasquez now on the mound
he is in joyce's old spot in the batting
order fastball strike three called he
got him looking could forto flip the bat
away he thought it was wide for ball
four the pitch
to alonso and right down the shoot of
called strike three back-to-back case
looking two outs here in the sixth
inning
here's dominic smith swinging a miss he
struck him out and vince velasquez joins
this remade phillies bullpen and he
strikes out the side in order and a
runner in scoring position now for
gregorius and dede hits a rocket down at
first great play by alonso from annie
strobin
and they get the out alonzo took a
double away from gregorius to keep the
mets in the lead catching the throw from
alonso but a great play by pete diving
to his left along the first baseline and
being able to catch the ball cleanly on
what was a hot shot off the bat of
gregorius a big second out as real muto
advanced to third segura singled and
lined out to first swinging a chopper
towards short vendor waits on it he's
got it has to hurry the throw and it's
just there in time to retire the side
so strowman gets through six
bases loaded one out seventh inning
leading two to one ball four nimmo takes
it low he sprints to first as velasquez
has walked four in the inning this time
he plates a run
gourmet touches home in the men's league
three to one a chance here to make his
first big mark on a potential mitt's
victory three to one mets in the seventh
bases loaded one out here's lindor and
lindora strokes one to center back goes
quinn he reels it in for the out but
tagging it third is mccann he'll come in
to score on the sacrifice fly for lindor
his first rbi is a met and the mets have
scored twice here in the seventh and
lead at four to one banner is conforto
pitch nemo takes off conforto takes the
pitch down rayo mutto's throw goes into
center field that'll enable pillar to
score
and it's five to one rail muto throwing
it to second on an o2 pitch with nemo
running and it carried into center field
and that enables pillar to waltz on home
four run lead now it's one and two on
conforto the pitch
down and in he skips out of the way it's
two balls two strikes i think it went
between his legs and jt caught him it
sure did
look at that
his legs
blocked it two-two pitch
there's a line drive to right moving to
his left is harper he can't get there
finally a hit for the mets as rounding
third nemo comes home to score conforto
slides safely into second the first hit
of the inning plates the mets fourth run
of the inning an rbi double for michael
conforto and it is a six to one mets
league
hoskins didn't start tonight only three
pinch hitting appearances in his career
one for three and a liner out to left
field that's a scorcher going back on it
is tom smith that's off the wall a run
is in hoskins holds up at first it's a
long rbi single it's 6-2
well if that ball gets in the air at all
it is well out of here it ball was
smoked hazley scored easily on that one
and rhys hoskins with his third run
batted in of the season and now harper
is one swing away from making this very
sticky can he make it a one-run game
swing in a line drive left center field
headed for the gap nimo's over makes the
catch stepping onto the warning track in
deep left center field nimo got a great
jump and he ran down a long drive off
the bat of harper i'd love to expand
your 4-1 lead if you can and here's just
the guy to do it
and he drops one of the air into deep
left field back toward the wall it's out
of here
peter lonzo with his first home run of
the season
a two-run shot and the mitts gets some
more distance it's now eight to two new
york glorious is home in this game
and reached on an infield hit so he's
two out of four
fly ball center field easing back is
elmora and he puts it away and the ball
game is over
jerry's familia finally closes the door
and the mets have their first victory of
the season